la unión europea sigue ampliando sus
sanciones tras la invasión de ucrania se
trata de un cuarto paquete de medidas a
partir de ahora varios oligarcas rusos
también estarán en la lista negra de la
unión europea se les prohibirá tener
acceso a sus bienes en la unión europea
y tampoco podrán entrar en territorio
comunitario asimismo también se amplía a
tres bancos viernes rusos la prohibición
de entrar en el sistema swift eso se
añade a los siete bancos rusos que ya no
forman parte desde la semana pasada
además se prohibirá la exportación de
equipo naval material para barcos y
software para que no se pueda volver a
enviar a rusia además también se
vigilará con más ahínco el uso que se
haga desde rusia de las cripto monedas
para evitar que puedan sortear de alguna
forma las sanciones impuestas por
occidente se trata de todo un paquete de
medidas pero que no se descarta que en
el futuro se pueda ampliar de hecho la
unión europea está estudiando futuras
medidas más adelante en todo caso las
medidas que se han tomado en estas dos
últimas semanas no tienen parangón de
hecho son totalmente inéditas en la
historia de la unión europea primero por
su celeridad pero también por su dureza
no obstante estas medidas también
tendrán un impacto en la economía
europea
indudable por ello los líderes europeos
también hablarán sobre esta cuestión en
una reunión en la ciudad francesa de
versalles a finales de esta semana